A team of archaeologists uncovers a giant
ceramic vase in the ruins of an ancient Greek
city.
They carefully brush away the sand and debris
that surrounds it.
The head archaeologist grabs a ladder and
places it gently against the 8-foot tall vase.
“I am going to see if there is anything
inside,” he says.
The archaeologist climbs the ladder and peers
over the lip of the ceramic vase.
The inside is completely black.
“I can’t see anything!” he shouts down
to the rest of the team.
He reaches his arm into the pot to see if
he can feel anything.
A couple of seconds later he releases a yelp
of pain.
“Something bit me!” he yells.
The archaeologist pulls his hand out of the
darkness and climbs down the ladder.
“Is there an animal inside?”
a fellow archaeologist asks.
But before the question can be answered, the
ceramic vase begins to shake.
Thousands of tiny creatures resembling a rat
mixed with a pug flood out of the top of the
vase.
They start clawing and biting the archaeologists.
The men run away screaming in terror.
Many are consumed by the wave of creatures;
others are overwhelmed as they try to scramble
up the ruins to safety.
Only minutes after the lead archaeologist
stuck his hand into the ceramic vase the screams
are silenced.
The creatures wander aimlessly around the
ancient Greek city.
The SCP Foundation hears of the incident and
sends a team to investigate.
They classify the anomalous vase as SCP-019.
When they arrive on the scene, the thousands
of creatures that were manifested from the
vase are found dead.
These entities are designated SCP-019-2 and
incinerated before any tourists visiting the
archaeological site see the corpses.
The extraction team examines the vase itself.
It seems like a normal, although very large,
ceramic from antiquity.
The scientists put in charge of securing SCP-019
are Doctor Light and Doctor Vaux.
“Be careful,” Light says.
“We don’t know what the connection is
between the vase and these creatures.
It seems as if they came out of it, but our
instruments aren’t detecting anything inside,
and there is no way they could have all fit
into that thing anyway.”
Doctor Vaux who is closely examining the vase
comes to the same conclusion.
They take a step back as the extraction team
prepares to put ropes in place to move SCP-019.
A rope is thrown over the vase; part of it
lands on top of the lip.
Instantly an instance of SCP-019-2 appears
from the ceramic.
It begins running around, clawing and biting
anything it can, but is eventually captured
by Doctor Vaux.
“Well, now we know where the creatures came
from.
We will bring it back to the lab for further
study,” the doctor says as he hands the
creature off to one of the agents.
The ropes are secured and the team begins
to move the vase, but with every movement,
another SCP-019-2 instance appears from the
artifact.
“This is going to get really annoying,”
says Doctor Light.
“Let’s put the whole damn thing in a mobile
containment chamber and let those little creatures
run on top of each other rather than us chasing
them around.”
“Agreed,” replies Vaux.
A containment pod is brought in.
The team quickly moves SCP-019 into it as
instance after instance of SCP-019-2 manifest
from the vase.
The doors to the pod are sealed.
Light and Vaux watch hundreds of small creatures
run around inside.
They bring the vase secured in the containment
pod back to the SCP Foundation site where
it can be studied further.
It is transferred to a containment chamber
where it is observed by Light and Voux.
After a few days, SCP-019 slows the manifestation
rate of the SCP-019-2 creatures.
When the vase was first secured, agents were
ordered to shoot the creatures on sight, but
the number of bullets being used was unreasonable,
so they resorted to flame-throwers.
The doctors decide the best course of action
is to put SCP-019 into a room hooked up to
an incinerator.
This way if too many creatures are manifested,
they can all be burnt to a crisp with the
push of a button.
Dr. Voux can’t help but think that this
must have been what Captain Kirk felt like
on the starship Enterprise when it became
infested with Tribbles.
Eventually, it is discovered that as long
as SCP-019 is kept at zero degrees Celsius,
and no one goes near it, the object only manifests
one creature per hour.
This is much easier to manage than the hordes
of SCP-019-2 instances that came out of the
vase previously.
Doctors Light and Vaux observe and collect
data on SCP-019 through a glass viewport that
looks into its containment chamber.
The incinerator is turned on at least once
every 24 hours just to clear the room of creatures.
When they are not working with the vase itself
the doctors examine SCP-019-2 entities to
try and understand what they are and what
they want.
They capture one of the creatures and put
it in a reinforced pen.
Light and Vaux provide the specimen with live
chickens for food and as much water as the
creature can drink.
The noises that SCP-019-2 makes sounds like
muffled sets of words.
When linguists are brought in they determine
that the vocalizations are phonetically similar
to Ancient Hellenic languages.
This is consistent with what was spoken at
the ancient Greek city where the ceramic vase
was found.
The doctors give the specimen a series of
puzzles to solve.
It can make its way through a maze to find
a piece of chicken.
But when it is given opportunities to show
its sentience, SCP-019-2 always falls short.
Doctor Light and Doctor Vaux determine the
creatures are about as intelligent as lab
rats.
One of the most peculiar things is that SCP-019-2
instances only live for less than 48 hours.
No matter how much food, water, or care is
given to the creatures they drop dead in a
day or two after being manifested.
Doctor Light moves one of the dead critters
to an operating room where it can be dissected.
She cuts down the middle of its stomach with
a scalpel and peels the skin and muscle away.
“Well, that explains that,” she says to
the other researchers standing in the room.
“The muscles seem to degrade rapidly from
the instant SCP-019-2 is manifested into our
world.
There is basically no digestive tract other
than a mouth and throat, but the most surprising
thing is the complete lack of internal organs.”
Doctor Vaux pushes the intercom button from
the viewing room in which he is observing
the procedure.
“What do you mean there are no internal
organs?
It must have some sort of brain and cardiovascular
system.”
“Yeah, but that’s about it,” Doctor
Light responds.
“There appears to be a very simple central
nervous system with a brain the size of a
pea, and a heart, but nothing else.
This creature can’t metabolize the food
it eats or filter out toxins, and I have no
idea how it breathes.
We need to run more tests.”
With each new specimen that’s examined the
results are the same.
The creatures aren’t very intelligent, they
die in under 48 hours, and they lack pretty
much any internal organs.
Then one day everything changes for the worst.
The guard posted to watch over SCP-019 notes
something strange occurred during his shift.
Without fail, the vase manifests an instance
of SCP-019-2 every hour, but around 3:00 AM,
no creature was generated, or at least that’s
what appeared to happen.
The guard puts on protective equipment and
enters the room to get a closer look, but
there is nothing there.
He locks up, records the anomaly, and returns
to the viewing glass to continue his watch.
Over the next hour the vase manifests a creature
as if everything is back to normal.
The next day, Light and Vaux arrive at work
to find everything in chaos.
The power in different sections of the facility
is failing.
It is as if something has gotten into the
ducts and is chewing through the wiring.
A team of agents uses thermal imaging devices
to track down the entity that is causing all
the mayhem.
They bring it back to the research lab.
“Take a look at this,” the agent says
pointing at an empty operating table.
He hands Doctor Light his thermal imaging
goggles.
Without them, there appears to be nothing
on the table, but when she looks through the
device, she can see an instance of SCP-019-2.
“My God,” Doctor Light whispers.
“They’re evolving.”
The creature is exactly the same as all the
others except this one is invisible.
Suddenly an alarm goes off and red warning
lights turn on across the facility.
Light rips off the goggles and looks at Doctor
Vaux.
“We need to get back to the vase now!”
she yells.
They sprint out of the operating room and
down the hall.
As they turn the corner they hear gunshots
and the spray of fire from flame-throwers.
On the other side of the corridor where SCP-019
is contained, there are agents battling with
thousands of instances of SCP-019-2.
The flame-throwers that had been so effective
at killing the creatures now appear useless.
It is as if the creatures have evolved some
sort of protective skin to combat the flames.
“Oh no,” gasps Doctor Light.
“We’ve gotta get out of here!”
She grabs Doctor Vaux’s shoulder and drags
him with her as she runs down the hall.
Behind them, the screams of agents can be
heard.
They are quickly muffled as thousands upon
thousands of SCP-019-2 creatures overwhelm
them.
Light glances behind her to see what is happening.
What she finds is a wall of creatures rushing
towards her.
There must be millions now.
It seems like SCP-019 was tired of being contained
by the Foundation and has sent an invasion
force to escape its captors.
“We’re not going to make it!”
Vaux yells.
He stumbles and falls to the ground.
Doctor Light skids to a stop and turns to
go back for him.
But it’s too late.
The wave of SCP-019-2 is closing in.
She watches in horror as Doctor Vaux is consumed
by the mass of creatures.
She turns and continues to run.
The exit is in sight.
Doctor Light makes a dash towards the door.
She can feel the tiny feet of the creatures
clawing at her heels.
She gives it everything she’s got and accelerates,
putting some distance between her and the
millions of SCP-019-2 entities.
Doctor Light slams through the exit door and
immediately closes it behind her.
She manages to slide the metal locking bar
into place.
The impact from the wave of creatures against
the door sends her stumbling backward.
She is safe now.
As Light lays on the ground panting and staring
at the door she thinks to herself.
Well, they’ll all be dead in a couple of
days and then we can try again.
Now watch “SCP-001 - Which is the Real 001?
(SCP Animation).”
Or check out “SCP-823 - Carnival of Horrors